Speaker 1: There is more bad news for Florida
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis. Ron DeSantis
as he is on his Asia tour. While there is a
flooding recovery happening in Florida that
includes long gas lines, the Santas in Asia like
a bobblehead, as we saw earlier this week. And he
is now getting sued by Disney World. I have been
saying for weeks Ron DeSantis is overplaying his
hand with the Anti-woke stuff. And Ron DeSantis is
really overplaying his hand with the anti Disney
stuff. And if you think Dominion Voting Systems
had good attorneys representing them against Fox
News, just wait until you see how good Disney's
attorneys are. CNBC reports Disney Sues Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis Alleges Political Effort
to Hurt its Business. Walt Disney Company sued
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis, alleging that
the Republican governor has waged a, quote,
relentless campaign to weaponize government power
over the company. You know, Republicans love to
use the word weaponize. And in fact, they are
holding they have been holding hearings since
taking over the House of Representatives
about the weaponization of government
and the weaponization of big tech. And, of course,
the terms are completely and wholly inappropriate
in those instances. If we are to accurately,
incorrectly use the term weaponization, it's
hard to think of a better example than what Ron
DeSantis has done with government power against
Walt Disney World as a retaliatory action for
Walt Disney World, saying we're against the Don't
Say gay bill. The article continues. The suit
dramatically escalates the feud between DeSantis,
who's expected to become a top Republican
contender in the 2024 presidential race
and Disney. The lawsuit was filed the same day
that a decent US backed board moved to undo a
development deal that it says Disney struck
to thwart its power. This is going to be.
A wild ride. And we've been talking about how
Trump's existing indictment and possible future
indictments might interfere with his presidential
primary campaign. DeSantis hasn't even announced
that he's running yet. We don't know if he will.
Increasingly, the polling is shaky or shakier and
shakier. But if he did, is it possible that the
chaos in Florida will become a distraction and an
impediment? Disney's attorneys, in all likelihood,
have had drafts of this lawsuit ready to go
since quite early on in this entire fiasco. And
as Ron DeSantis kept finding new ways to, yes,
weaponize Florida government against Disney,
they continue to add to those lawsuit drafts.
They were waiting for the board to vote. And now
that the board has voted, they are suing. Now,
I want to be really clear, because I know some
of you are going to write to me and say, David,
it's weird to see a progressive, gleeful about
the uber capitalist corporation, Walt Disney
World. Folks, this this is not about that. I
don't like Disney. I mean, I've said before,
I hate theme parks. When I went to Disney World,
it was just horrifying, overpriced, ridiculously
overpriced, terrible food, long lines. And I hate
all of it. Okay. Walt Disney was an anti-Semite,
just like I don't like anything about Disney,
but if I step back and look at the facts,
DeSantis is in the wrong here. From everything
that has been publicly reported. Obviously,
at some point when we say, well, is he in
the wrong, there has to be an adjudication,
we have a lawsuit here and we may have a
version of that adjudication. And this is
a crusade that I have been telling you for a
while really may backfire. And even though I
don't like. So there's the sociocultural part and
then there's the legal part on the socio cultural
part. I recognize that just because I can't stand
Disney World doesn't mean that tens of millions,
hundreds of millions of people absolutely love
it. And picking a fight with Disney is potentially
a losing battle, just that at its face. That's
number one. And number two, as we've said before,
aside from Disney, specifically, the country
for the most part, is on the woke side,
not the Anti-woke side. And, you know, the
don't say gay whip bill was a big part of
the Disney controversy with Ron DeSantis. We had
a recent poll which asked Americans on the whole,
Do you think that society has done too much,
not enough or about the right amount when it
comes to protecting whatever LGBT folks and the
balance was on? We've done the right amount or
not enough. In other words, the majority of the
country doesn't think that woke is going too far
or whatever phraseology the right wants to apply
to it. So we'll see about the legal aspect of it.
Certainly when it comes to the socio cultural in
all sorts of different ways, Ron DeSantis seems to
have dramatically overstepped here. We will watch
it. But this is a crusade that may well backfire.